ausschreitungen bei demos in berlin
obwohl eine große querdenker
demonstration in der hauptstadt verboten
wurde haben sich zahlreiche corona regel
gegner aufgemacht ihrer wut ausdruck zu
verschaffen und dabei kommt es schon am
vormittag zu einigen ausschreitungen bei
der die polizei hart durchgreift sie
sind mit rund 2250 beamten im einsatz
da viele der demonstranten keinen
mundschutz tragen und auch immer wieder
versuchten polizeisperren zu
durchbrechen kommt es zuerst
eskalationen am späten samstagabend
wurde die vermeintliche haupt demo der
initiative querdenken 711 aus stuttgart
vom oberverwaltungsgericht verboten
sie war mit 22.500 teilnehmern an der
straße des 17 juni angemeldet gewesen
diese und andere protestzüge wurden
untersagt weil teilnehmende regelmäßig
regelung etwa zum infektionsschutz nicht
akzeptieren
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren